J'espère qu'on puisse conclure avec la considération du fruit de l'esprit aujourd'hui,
avec les trois derniers éléments qui nous manquent à considérer.
Et cette conception du fruit de l'esprit est une conception véritablement très riche
et c'est qui est tout simplement les chrétiens.
C'est la description de notre nouvelle nature,
car c'est aussi une manière de décrire la symétrie parfaite du caractère du Christ,
du caractère des dieux lui-même.
Et si nous sommes les résultats de cette œuvre rédemptrice des dieux en Christ,
nous sommes les fruits de l'esprit quelque part.
Les fruits de l'esprit, elle est chrétien.
Les fruits de l'esprit sont les petits Christ que nous sommes,
après avoir expérimenté cette expérience de conversion.
Donc les fruits de l'esprit, il nous est présenté dans les sanguliers,
car ses vertus sont indivisibles,
elles doivent toujours se manifester de manière harmonique, symétrique,
et tous ces éléments doivent composer les caractères,
la manifestation d'un chrétien,
car ils sont tous trouvés parfaitement en harmonie avec Jésus-Christ.
Et donc, l'apôtre Paul, il est en train de faire ses rappels envers les Galates,
car malgré la réalité de l'expérience de conversion des Galates,
malgré le fait que les Galates avaient déjà manifesté avec une certaine constance,
et cohérence et symétrie,
cette nouvelle nature qu'ils ont reçue du Christ en ayant été greffée à Christ par la foi,
malgré les faits que les Galates avaient bien commencé leur course,
et donc naturellement fonctionné pendant une saison,
dans la direction de ses fruits,
ils étaient en train de vivre un moment des crises en tant qu'Église,
et une crise dont leur comportement visible,
dont l'ambiance à cette Église,
était marquée par la division.
C'est un groupe
qui voulait suggérer
qu'après la conversion,
pour mener la vie avec Dieu,
il fallait révenir en arrière
et s'adapter
aux habitudes rigoureuses
de la religion juive corrompue
afin de préserver
ou développer les saluts.
Donc les judaïsants
qui étaient en fondant français,
un groupe de cette Église.
Un autre groupe de cette Église,
dans une réaction extrême,
disait, non, Christ a tout fait,
Christ va tout garantir
et il était en train de faire osage
de leur liberté
comme un prétexte
pour tomber
dans les péchés de la chair.
Particulièrement
l'immoralité sexuelle,
même l'animosité,
et les moques des maîtrises de soi
dans leur rapport
envers certaines choses
qui peuvent être bonnes dans la vie,
comme la nourriture
ou l'alcool,
mais de manière exagérée.
Et il y avait un groupe
qui était correct
dans leur compréhension biblique,
et qui était en train de suivre
ce qui était l'un des objectifs
principaux de l'apôtre Paul
dans la lettre.
C'était de communiquer
de manière claire et limpide
que la justification
qui nous touche
lorsque nous sommes convertis,
nous tous les chrétiens,
nous sommes sauvés
par la foi à Jésus seul.
et il y a deux aspects principaux
de cette notion
des justifications.
Donc, pourquoi on a besoin
des justifications ?
Car nous sommes tous corrompus.
On est tous pécheurs,
aucun autre monde
a la capacité d'élu
d'un auteur
de sa propre conscience,
encore plus
de la loi des dieux révélée.
Et étant tous serrés
sous condamnation,
nous avons tous besoin
d'un substitut.
quelqu'un qui puisse
nous représenter
devant les tribunaux
des dieux,
qui puisse vivre
une vie parfaite
à notre place
et qui soit puni
à cause de nos péchés
pour qu'ils puissent
payer cette double dette,
donner à Dieu
en notre faveur,
à notre place,
une obéissance parfaite
qui Christ a conquis
par sa vie
et associer à Christ.
Nous pouvons donc
présenter à Dieu
une obéissance parfaite,
mais comme nous sommes
transgresseurs aussi,
Dieu doit punir Christ
pour satisfaire
les justes exigences
de sa loi.
Un Dieu juste
va punir,
il ne peut pas laisser
encunir les péchés.
Et donc Christ,
avec sa vie,
nous crédite
sur l'obéissance parfaite.
Christ, avec sa mort,
il satisfait
cette punition
qu'on méritait.
Et donc nous pouvons
nous présenter
devant Dieu
avec notre dette
complètement effacée
et avec un crédit
d'obéissance
suprême.
Et donc à partir de là,
nous sommes
changés de position
devant Dieu
si nous avons,
si nous nous sommes
associés à Christ
en tant que représentants.
Donc devant Dieu,
on est en train
de reconnaître
notre condamnation,
notre état pécheur
et on est en train
de dire à Dieu,
voici,
je me présente devant toi,
non sur la base
de mon obéissance,
mon performance,
mais sur la base
de l'œuvre
parfaite du Christ.
Et donc on est
justifié
dans une dimension
légale,
dans un tribunal légal.
On est déclaré juste
de la part de Dieu
car on a été
justement justifié.
Dieu a dû agir
avec justice
envers Christ
à notre place
pour qu'il nous puisse
être déclaré
juste devant Dieu.
C'est un changement
définitif
de position
pour tous ceux
qui sont véritablement
associés à Christ
par la foi
pour la conversion.
Il n'y a plus jamais
la possibilité
que par cette justification
en étant adopté
légalement par Dieu
en Christ,
c'est impossible
que Dieu
nous traite
sur la base
de notre performance.
Car nous avons pris
une décision définitive
pour qu'on soit
traité par Dieu
sur la base
de l'obéissance
et de la performance
de Jésus-Christ.
Ok ?
La position
est changée
pour toujours.
Sauf que l'intérêt
de nous sauver
n'a jamais été
un intérêt
tout simplement
de nous délivrer
de la culpabilité
tout simplement
du péché.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Dieu a voulu
nous délivrer
de la condition
d'esclavage
du péché
et de sa pollution.
Et donc,
tout ce que Dieu
a déclaré
juste véritablement,
tous ceux
qui sont associés
à Christ
de manière légale
ou fédérale,
ce sont ceux
qui ont subi
à une transformation
de la part
de Dieu
dans la racine
de leur être.
C'est la conception
des régénérations,
des nouvelles natures,
des nouvelles créations.
Ils sont devenus
habitations
de Saint-Esprit
et par l'Esprit
ils ont été greffés
à Christ.
C'est-à-dire,
on n'est pas
qu'adoptés
en Jésus,
on a été greffés
à Christ,
les fils de Dieu.
Et donc,
ceux qui ont été
légalement adoptés
par Dieu,
par la foi,
ce sont ceux
qui subiront
une transformation
si radicale
dans leur nature
qu'ils passeront
progressivement
à se conformer
à Christ.
Ceux qui ont été
adoptés
en tant qu'enfants
des dieux
deviennent
de plus en plus
similaires
effectivement
à son père
et au fils des dieux
par excellence
qui est le Sainte-Dieu.
Et donc,
cette justification
nous explique
l'apôtre Paul
dans la plupart
de sa lettre,
c'est une justification
qui a deux dimensions.
Une dimension légale,
amputée,
et une dimension
infuse,
transformation réelle.
Par condition,
nous sommes déclarés
justes une fois pour toutes
et par expérience,
nous sommes vivifiés
par l'esprit
étant le référent
de Christ.
Donc,
c'est impossible,
comme disait
Spurgeon,
de nous reposer
avec une assurance
de salut
qui soit strictement
légale,
sans voir les fruits
de l'esprit
dans nos vies.
Ne vous donnez
jamais repos,
disait Spurgeon,
pour vous considérer
chrétien
si vous ne voyez pas
les évidences
de filiation
dans vos vies.
Donc,
quel est l'objectif
de l'apôtre Paul
avec toute cette
première partie
de la lettre ?
C'est d'arriver ici
pour pouvoir
exhorter cette église
à marcher
dans l'esprit.
La solution
la plus efficace
pour cette division
au sein de cette église
n'était pas
de donner
des nouvelles révélations
ou ordres
à ces personnes
sur comment
ils allaient faire
pour régler les choses.
La solution
n'est pas basée
sur les fers,
la solution
est basée
sur la conscience
des l'êtres.
Et l'exhortation
c'est tout simplement
vivez à la hauteur
de votre nouvelle nature.
Au lieu de donner
occasion à la chair,
au reste de la chair
qui sont en train
de vous encourager
à vous disputer
de plus en plus,
à avoir raison
par orgueil,
c'est que l'apôtre Paul
est en train de dire
vivez plutôt
en accord
avec les élans
organiques
et naturels
de votre conversion
à la manière du Christ
de régler les problèmes,
manifester les fruits
de l'esprit
au sein de cette église.
Donc les fruits
de l'esprit
deviennent pour nous
de manière très claire
un test
pour l'évaluation
du salut authentique
car nous devons tous
constater
ces fruits
dans nos vies.
Mais
en tous ceux
pour qui c'est vrai
avoir ces fruits,
c'est aussi
une exhortation
pour qu'on soit
intentionnel
à manifester
ces fruits.
C'est-à-dire
si pendant
la saison
les Galates
se sont disputés
de manière
orgueilleuse
ou sont retombés
dans quelques péchés
d'immoralité
sexuelle
ou
des mentes
et maîtresses
de soi,
ils doivent
être résolus
au lieu
d'agir
selon les élans
de leur vie
passée,
être résolus
à manifester
ce qui montre
que selon
les paramètres
du Nouveau Testament
la progression
en scientification
ne se fera pas
avec une absence
complète
de la résistance
de la chair.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Par contre,
cette exagération
qu'on voit dans la
génération d'église
sur la puissance
de la chair,
elle n'a pas
débaté de lui.
car la description
ici,
c'est
marcher selon
l'esprit
et vous
n'accomplirez
plus jamais
les désirs
de la chair.
Car la chair
a des désirs
contraires
à ceux
de l'esprit,
l'esprit
a des contraires
à ceux
de la chair,
ils sont opposés
entre eux.
Sauf que
cette opposition
n'est pas entre
forces égales.
Car ceux
qui sont
Jésus-Christ
et c'est
l'entraide,
ont déjà
crucifié
la chair.
Les forces
de la chair
chez les chrétiens
véritables
sont les forces
d'une nature
qui est en train
de mourir,
qui a déjà
subi un coup
mortel.
Et l'une des raisons
pour les paramètres
si rébaissés
dans nos églises
aujourd'hui
des saint-été,
la conception
non-biblique
et unique
des chrétiens
charnels
qui n'existaient pas
dans la Bible,
elles sont plutôt
dues
à une
exagération
par rapport
à la force
de la chair
et des tentations.
C'est une négligence
incroyable
envers
la nouvelle nature
du chrétien
dont la volonté
nouvelle
est prédominamment
dirigée
pour plaire Dieu
et un accord
avec la volonté
de Dieu
couplé
à la présence
de la présentation
de la sainte unité
en nous,
le Saint-Esprit.
Et donc
le Saint-Esprit
exerce une influence
infiniment plus puissante
car vivifiante
envers les fruits
de l'Esprit
et nous avons
la nature
qui veut
produire
les fruits
de l'Esprit.
Et donc
dans cette
bataille
réelle,
nous ne sommes pas
des ventes,
des forces
des mêmes mesures.
Et donc
ici,
le rapôtre Paul
veut restaurer
cette conscience
afin qu'il soit
résolue.
Donc les fruits
de l'Esprit
sont donc
présentés
comme cet élément
que tous les chrétiens
ont dû expérimenter
de manière radicale
au moment de la conversion.
On peut avoir
des moments
d'oscillation
par rapport
au fruit
de l'Esprit,
des moments
d'oscillation
pour céder
un peu
aux œuvres
de la chair
encore,
au reste
de la chair.
Par contre,
tous les vrais chrétiens
au moment de la conversion
ont dû expérimenter
cette transformation
radicale,
l'expérience
personnelle
d'avoir été
convaincu
et expérimenté
la puissance
efficace
pour que nous
nous sentons
affranchis
véritablement
des désirs
de la chair.
Avant,
on n'arrivait pas
à dire non
constamment
au désir
de la chair.
Après la conversion,
on a été
affranchis.
Notre désir
pour plaire
Dieu,
la joie
qu'on a expérimenté
en Christ
a surnommé
l'attrait
de tous ces faux plaisirs
et tous ces plaisirs
corrompus.
Étant satisfaits
en Dieu
et en Christ,
on avait
la motivation
réelle
pour dire non
aux appels
de la chair.
Et c'est par les mentions
de cette relation
avec le Christ
que nous pouvons
manifester
constamment.
Car
les mêmes esprits
qui nous ont unis
à Christ
au moment de la conversion,
c'est l'esprit
qui est venu
définitivement
démeurer en nous
et dont
les ministères
principales
du Saint-Esprit
aident
de produire
les fruits
de l'esprit
en nous
et de nous pousser
à la conformité
et l'intimité
avec Christ.
Et donc,
si c'est ça
la réalité
du chrétien,
tous les chrétiens
et que les chrétiens
ont expérimenté
radicalement
ces aventures
au moment de la conversion
et ont à leur disposition
tout ce qu'il faut
pour manifester
constamment,
pour renouveler
la manifestation
de ces choses
dans leur vie.
Voilà pourquoi
nous trouvons ici
la base
d'assurance
de l'apôtre Paul
que cette communauté
peut être redressée.
il n'a pas besoin
de rester
dans les accusations,
il n'a pas besoin
de rester
sur les menaces,
il n'est pas en train
de chercher
à proposer
quelques motivations
si vous vous redressez
Dieu va mieux
vous traiter.
Ce n'est pas
sur la base
de la performance
que la faveur
de Dieu
va se manifester
dans leur vie.
Ce qu'il est en train
de dire tout simplement
vivez
en conformité
avec ce qui représente
vos désirs
les plus profonds
c'est que vous avez
déjà expérimenté
de votre vie
cette puissance
qui vous a franchi
de la chair
et donc vivez
à la hauteur
de ce que vous pouvez
vivre.
On a considéré
donc les éléments
du fruit de l'esprit
dans cette composition
inséparable,
indivisible
et on peut
les diviser
pour qu'on puisse
faire un résumé
un peu plus court
entre trois triades
l'amour,
la joie
et la paix
qui décrivent
plutôt
la condition
antérieure
du chrétien,
l'état
d'esprit
du chrétien
comme résultat
immédiat
de leur conversion.
Donc c'est
une joie,
un amour,
une paix
que les mondes
ne peuvent pas connaître
car elles sont
enracinées
dans cette réconciliation
avec la source
suprême
d'amour.
La quête
pour l'amour,
la paix
et la joie
c'est une quête
qui marque
l'humanité
et l'humanité
essaie de combler
ses vides
avec des choses
qui n'ont jamais
la capacité
de les satisfaire
pleinement.
Mais quand on voit
la manière
dont par la réconciliation
avec Dieu,
on a connu
la taille
ou l'intensité
de l'amour
des dieux
révélée pour nous
en Jésus Christ
en donnant son fils
pour moi et pour nous,
on a cette expérience
de satisfaction
pleine,
une satisfaction
telle
qui surmonte
même notre capacité
de nous satisfaire.
Voilà pourquoi
la description
c'est débordant
des joies.
Un amour reçu
qui déborde
des satisfactions
et qui déborde
dans les yeux
dans les relations
car nous ne pouvons
pas nous empêcher
de mener
une vie marquée.
par l'amour,
la joie et la paix.
Réconcilier avec Dieu,
avec la certitude
que cette réconciliation
était efficace
et qu'elle assure
notre futur
pour toute la gloire,
en paix avec Dieu,
si c'est Dieu
qui gouverne
toutes les choses,
qui peuvent menacer
notre vie fragile,
il est un Dieu pour nous
qui nous traite
comme un des enfants,
comme un Christ lui-même,
il n'y a aucune menace
qui puisse enlever
ou supprimer la paix
de vrais chrétiens.
Et donc,
les chrétiens,
il est marqué
par cette condition,
par cet état
qui est radical en lui
et qui est débordant
en lui
envers les autres.
Les chrétiens
n'ont pas besoin
lorsqu'ils fonctionnent
en sanité spirituelle,
des psychotropes,
des antidépressifs,
des calmants,
d'aides pour dormir.
car la réalité
de notre conversion
lorsque nous nous plongeons
dans la considération
de ces phénomènes
glorieux
qui a été notre conversion,
nous voyons
que Dieu est la source
suprême des joies,
Dieu est la communication
suprême d'amour
et être en paix
avec Dieu
nous assure
d'avoir la paix
envers toutes les choses
qui pourraient être ainsi.
et donc
une cohérence
avec ses fondements,
ses fruits
qui a interconnecté
va manifester
dans sa relation
envers les autres.
Donc la deuxième priade,
elle parle
de cette prédisposition
ou cette attitude
d'esprit
envers les autres
qui est fondée
sur la manière
dont Dieu nous a traités
dans l'évangile.
étant débordant
d'amour,
c'est-à-dire
que je n'ai pas trop
de carences
envers les autres,
étant débordant
des joies,
mes relations
n'ont plus besoin
d'être utilitaires,
étant débordant
des paix,
je sais qu'il y en a
été traité
pas selon ce que
j'ai mérité
mais avec grâce
pour me réconcilier
avec Dieu,
ma détermination
c'est d'agir
avec patience
envers les autres
afin qu'ils soient aussi
réconciliés avec Dieu.
Et donc la patience,
la bénéglité
et la bonté
ne sont pas
des attitudes
qu'on puisse
mesurer.
C'est tout simplement
un déclenchement
naturel
et ces vertus
qui ont été formées
et fondées
sur l'amour chrétien,
la joie chrétienne
et la paix chrétienne
qui vont se porter
envers les autres
avec cette cohérence.
Donc c'est une patience
qui je vous rappelle
qui n'était pas
une patience
tout simplement
qui veut éviter
les problèmes
mais c'est une patience
dans l'intentionnalité
d'être bénant
car nous sommes bons.
Donc fidélité,
douceur,
pardon,
patience,
bénéglité
et bonté.
C'est-à-dire
la patience
qui peut endurer
l'opposition
car nous sommes déjà
dans un état
de félicité suprême.
Et nous savons
que cette opposition
c'est une opposition
envers les biens
qu'on vise à produire
chez eux.
et donc c'est une patience
qui vise
promouvoir la réconciliation,
la même réconciliation
qu'on a vécue
avec Dieu
et voilà pourquoi
les chrétiens
supportent
la résistance
et l'opposition.
Et ensuite,
cette patience
elle est constamment
dans la dynamique
de la délimité,
cet élan antérieur,
cette attitude
envers les autres
de reproduire
la générosité
avec laquelle
Dieu nous a traités.
Dieu qui nous a délivrés
par sa patience
de l'enfer
qui a dirigé
sa juste scolaire
des nôtres
envers son fils
afin de pouvoir
nous faire asseoir
avec Christ
dans les régions célestes
avec toutes les bénédictions
spirituelles.
Donc c'est
du sommet
du fond du puits
au sommet
du lieu
le plus élevé
et les chrétiens
est la personne
la plus riche
de l'univers.
Il ne va pas chercher
à aider les personnes
selon la base
de ce qu'il mérite,
de ce qu'il peut
les manquer
ni selon la base
de ce qu'il m'a
pensé à voir
sur notre entendance.
Il est
dès soi-même
en tant que vertu
quelqu'un
qui est généreux
envers les autres.
Il est déterminé
à être toujours
en train de se manifester
avec bénéglité
envers les autres.
Et nous voyons aussi
qu'il devient donc
il peut devenir
patient et bénant
comme on a vu
car sa nature
a été changée.
Il est devenu bon.
Dieu a changé
son cœur.
C'est la pureté
de cœur
et c'est cette bonté
qui permet
qu'on agisse
comme ça.
Et donc,
ce sont les élans
ou les attitudes
qu'on a à l'église.
Et aujourd'hui,
on va considérer
la fidélité,
la douceur
et la tempérance.
Et là,
à nouveau,
un point,
un comment
entre ces trois points
ou ces trois éléments,
c'est la question
de la constance
dans la pratique.
Si vous voulez
imaginer un fruit,
ces fruits,
il aura
les mêmes goûts,
la même forme,
peu importe
dans quel pays
il habite
et les deux.
Donc,
nous sommes
devant
trois éléments
qui justifient
ou expliquent
quelque part
la fiabilité
du fruit
lui-même.
donc,
qu'est-ce qui va
assurer
ses goûts,
les goûts
de ses fruits,
cette douceur ?
Qu'est-ce qui peut
expliquer
cette fiabilité
lorsque je suis
devant un chrétien ?
Qu'est-ce qui peut
m'attendre
de lui
en termes
des comportements,
des traitements ?
De quelle manière
il va m'éner
ses relations
envers moi ?
De quelle manière
il mène sa relation
avec Dieu
dans les privés
lorsque personne
n'est en train
de regarder
la même vie ?
Cette tempérance,
cette maîtrise
des soins.
Et donc,
c'est une constance
qui n'est pas
fragmentée.
Ce ne sont pas
des personnes
qui sont douces
envers les autres,
mais ce sont des personnes
qui sont en train
de se maîtriser
constamment
car elles vivent
leur vie
devant Dieu
avant tout,
devant Christ
pour qu'il soit
fiable
dans ses relations
et de être fiable
dans sa relation
privée avec Dieu.
Pour que cette constance
ait lieu,
il faut que ces personnes
soient fidèles
à la manière
dont Dieu
a prescrit
que nous devrions vivre
à la manière
dont Christ a vécu
avec cette fidélité
constante.
Et donc,
la fidélité,
la douceur
et la tempérance,
elles ont ces points
en commun.
Elles justifient
la manière
dont nous pouvons
être fiables
en tant que
fruit d'esprit.
C'est la constance
du fruit.
C'est intéressant,
avant de rentrer
dans les détails
pour la compréhension
biblique
de chacun de ces termes,
que l'expérience
de tous les chrétiens,
c'est de retrouver
ces qualités
car elles deviennent
quelque part
les qualités
les plus évidentes.
Alors,
la patience,
c'est un exercice
évident,
mais pas très apparent
et la bénignité,
parfois,
peut se confondre
avec les fausses
libéralités
qui peuvent avoir
d'autres motivations.
mais c'est intéressant
qu'il y a
que, peu importe
qu'on soit
dans les mondes
et qu'on croise
avec la vie
d'un chrétien,
c'est ça
qui peut ressortir
les plus.
Cette sensation
de fidélité,
de savoir que
nous pouvons confier
à une personne
nos biens
s'ils nous demandent,
on ne les demande
même pas pourquoi
car il s'agit
d'une personne
constante
dans sa fidélité.
C'est une personne
qui est créative
dans les détails
de sa vie,
qui nous pose
des questions
constamment
pour savoir
comment ils doivent agir
pour qu'ils soient
sûrs d'être fidèles
à Dieu
dans ce qu'ils font.
Ce sont des personnes
qui nous pouvons
nous assurer
que si jamais
ils ont
des relations
plus intimes
avec nous,
c'est pas par intérêt
et qu'ils seront
fidèles
dans leur désir
de promouvoir
notre vie
et prendre quelque chose
prêté
et de les rendre
encore dans un mieux état
que ce qu'ils ont trouvé.
C'est comme Christ
que lorsqu'il prenait
à prêter
certaines choses,
il rendait toujours
avec une valeur ajoutée.
C'est cette fidélité,
cette loyauté
dans leur relation
savoir que si nous partageons
certains détails
de nos vies
ou en cas difficile
qu'on a conspetté,
cela ne va pas sortir.
Il y aura.
La douceur,
c'est tout simplement
les goûts
de ces traitements
qu'on a
et qu'on reçoit.
On va visiter
les chrétiens
dans d'autres parts du monde
et ils nous traiteront
en la douceur.
Ce sont des personnes
qui nous voyons constamment
en train d'ouvrir
le monde
de leurs doigts
afin de promouvoir
les gens des autres.
Dans les petites choses,
dans les grandes choses,
ils ont un niveau de force,
ils peuvent avoir
un niveau d'influence,
mais leur intérêt majeur,
c'est de ne pas rendre
les personnes inconfortables,
de ne pas réclamer
leurs droits
tous les temps.
C'est l'opposé
du discours
qu'on voit dans le jour
que Dieu a fait
des routes des têtes
et non que.
D'aller dans l'été
rendre les nids
pour régagner
tout ce qui nous a volé.
C'est cette douceur
qui prend en considération
que les personnes
qui interagissent
avec nous
sont constamment
sous l'attaque
de la chair,
de sa tendre
et du monde
et qui sont très considératives
dans leur traitement.
Tout simplement,
c'est cette impression
des douceurs.
Et la conférence
passe par cette notion
de maîtrise des soins
et d'équilibre.
Donc, ce n'est pas
l'austérité démoniaque
dont l'apôtre Paul
va convenir,
ce n'est pas
de chercher à se priver
de manière très méthodique
de plusieurs choses,
mais c'est un équilibre.
Ce sont des personnes
qui sont tout simplement
équilibrées.
Elles ne sont pas
hypersensibles,
mais elles savent aussi
s'y faire respecter.
Elles réjouissent
de leur dire,
mais elles savent aussi
dire non.
Ce sont des personnes
qui ne sont pas
tous les temps,
dans tous les moments,
dans toutes les situations,
en train de trop calculer
leur manière de se comporter.
Mais nous,
voilà,
de manière très claire,
ce sont des personnes
qui sont constamment
en train de se contener.
Et donc,
voilà,
de manière résumée,
mais nous devons
faire plus que ça.
Donc,
comment nous pouvons
expérimenter
et manifester constamment,
comment nous pouvons
nous préserver
ou cultiver constamment
la fidélité,
la douceur
et la tempérance
de l'esprit ?
Donc,
la première chose
qu'on va faire,
c'est de considérer
la compréhension
biblique
de ses vertus.
Car,
comme on est considéré
avec chacun
de ses éléments,
on peut avoir
toujours l'impression
qu'un être humain
qui n'est pas né
de nouveau,
qui n'est pas chrétien,
peut manifester
ces choses.
Et dans une certaine
mesure,
nous appelons
ces vertus
avec les mêmes mots
parfois.
Mais c'est clair
qu'étant
fruit de l'esprit,
il s'agit
des vertus spirituelles
qui ne peuvent
être enviandées
par l'esprit.
Ce sont des caractéristiques
exclusives
des chrétiens.
Et ce sont
des caractéristiques
obligatoires
chez les chrétiens.
Et la question
qu'on va se poser,
c'est
quelles sont
ces vertus
que je dois constater
chez moi
et manifester
chez moi.
Donc,
pour considérer
la définition biblique
des fidélités,
pour commencer
par la fidélité,
n'est pas quelque chose
qui soit accessible
à l'homme naturel.
Donc,
nous devons faire
la distinction
avec l'impression
qu'on a
de ce qui est
la fidélité
chez les hommes.
Chez les hommes,
la fidélité,
elle est fragmentée.
Les hommes
ne sont pas constants
dans leur fidélité,
dans leur fiabilité
tous les temps.
la racine du terme,
elle signifie
tout simplement
foi,
mais aussi
avec signification
de fidélité
et fiabilité.
Donc,
quelque part,
la fidélité,
elle est proportionnelle
à la confiance
qu'on fait
dans la vie.
et donc,
les personnes
qui devraient être fiables,
comme par exemple
ceux qui sont adeptes
de certaines idéologies
ou parfois même
partis politiques,
mais qui réunissent
constamment
leur propre
soi-disant valeur.
Car dans la pratique,
ils ne sont pas
en train des
développeurs
de leur propre
conviction.
Ils ne peuvent pas
être fidèles
à leur conviction
car leurs convictions
de soi-même
ne sont pas
si fiables.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et la réalité,
c'est que pour nous
les chrétiens,
nous pouvons être fidèles,
nous devons être fidèles,
car nos convictions,
les fondements
de notre foi,
de ce qui compose
nos valeurs
majeures,
c'est le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ lui-même,
l'être
le plus fidèle,
l'explication
de la vie
la plus fidèle,
les valeurs
les plus fidèles
fondées
sur un caractère
innoir
d'un Dieu
innoir.
Par contre,
cette fidélité
fragmentée
dans les vies
de personnes,
c'est la liaison
de leur conviction
même,
parfois dans la pratique.
Ce sont les trous
dans leur vision
du monde,
mais aussi
dans leur relation.
Quand on voit par exemple
que certaines personnes
peuvent être fiables
en tant qu'ils sont bons
professionnels,
et parfois ils sont déterminés
à être des bons
professionnels,
mais ils ne sont ni fidèles
ni fiables
dans leur vie
privée.
Certains parents
peuvent être fidèles
et fiables
dans l'automatisme
de leurs tâches.
Je veux
pouvoir
à ma maison,
mais pas
intégralement
fidèles et fiables
comme parents.
Car il y a
beaucoup plus
que ça
en tant qu'il rôle
envers les enfants.
Il ne faut pas
les déposer
à l'école,
il faut suivre
ceux qui sont
en train de l'étudier.
Il faut être fidèle
envers les enfants
car ce n'est pas
à l'état
d'élever nos enfants,
de soigner
nos enfants.
Ce n'est pas
une fidélité
fragmentée.
il s'agit
d'un fruit
fondé
non sur
un époir
personnel.
Car parfois,
l'orgueil
peut être
la motivation
d'une personne
d'être perçue
comme fiable
comme c'était
pour les parisiens.
Ils aimaient bien
être vus
comme les fidèles.
Mais la réalité,
c'est qu'au fond
de leur cœur,
leur motivation
était pour être
vue par les autres.
Certaines personnes,
même au sein de l'Église,
peuvent servir
longtemps fidèlement
dans une mer
dont leur intérêt
majeur,
c'est d'être
vus
comme un membre
fidèle.
Et c'est la même
chose par rapport
à la fidélité
qu'ils peuvent
porter à l'Église
et qu'ils n'aient pas
parfois comportés
à leur propre maison.
Donc,
la motivation
pour être fidèle
ne peut pas être
être fidèle
à moi-même.
Même si cette fidélité
réelle
à nous-mêmes
chez les chrétiens
n'est pas complètement
effacée.
Car nous,
nous devons être fidèles
à nous-mêmes
en tant que chrétiens
et tant qu'image
des dieux.
Et donc,
ce n'est pas non plus
à la proportion
des circonstances
ou des mérites
d'un autre.
Paul,
lorsqu'il écrit
à Timothée,
au deuxième Timothée
chapitre 2,
il nous rappelle
en fait
que nous devons
être fidèles
dans nos relations
avec les autres
car notre fidélité
est fondée
sur la fidélité
du Christ.
Donc,
il dit,
au verset 10,
c'est pourquoi
je supporte tout
à cause des élus.
Vous voyez,
il est fidèle
dans sa détermination
à souffrir
pour promouvoir
la vie des autres
afin qu'eux aussi
obtiennent
les saluts
qui ont Jésus-Christ
avec la gloire éternelle.
Cette parole est certaine.
Si nous sommes
morts avec lui,
nous vivrons aussi
avec lui.
Si nous persévérons,
nous régnerons aussi
avec lui.
Donc,
persévérance,
on attribue
des fidélités.
Et si nous le régnons,
lui aussi
nous réunira.
si nous sommes
infidèles,
il demeure fidèle
car il ne peut pas
s'éreigner lui-même.
Quelle est l'attente
de notre détermination
à la fidélité
à fonctionner
comme un fruit,
un fruit
qui sera patient,
qui cherchera
à produire
les saluts des perdus,
même sous souffrance.
C'est cette fidélité
qui est fondée
sur la fidélité
du Seigneur
du Christ lui-même.
Et donc,
nous sommes fiables
lorsque nous sommes
fidèles
à la fidélité
du Christ.
Et donc,
ce n'est pas
une fidélité
tout simplement
superficielle
ou externe.
Ce n'est pas
une question
de cocher
les cases.
C'est une question
à nouveau
à défaire
en soi-même
parce que
c'est manifeste
par l'éterre
mais c'est une question
des vertus.
Une personne,
voilà la question
chez nos cœurs
qui a été engendrée
par l'esprit
qui est unie à Christ,
elle n'est pas
à prendre
et se demander
tout simplement
qu'est-ce que je dois faire
pour être plus fidèle.
C'est une fidélité
radicale
qui a été opérée
au plus profond
de nos cœurs
envers
les Seigneurs
du Christ.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Nous agissons
avec fidélité
car notre foi
en soi-même
dans sa nature
est une question
d'allégeance
envers Christ.
Nous avons
embrassé Christ
comme notre Seigneur
par une foi
qui a été
conquise,
qui a conquis
notre loyauté
complète
et radicale.
Et donc,
cette vertu
des caractères
chrétiens,
la fidélité,
elle est proportionnelle
à la confiance
que nous avons en Dieu,
à la foi.
Et donc,
les plus grands
sont Dieu pour nous,
sont l'œuvre du Christ,
les plus grands
sont l'amabilité
des dieux envers nous,
sont les seigneuries
du Christ envers nous,
sont son autorité
pour nous,
les plus grands
sont sa puissance,
sont notre crainte
envers lui
en tant que Seigneur,
les plus grands
sera notre fidélité
dans la pratique.
Ceux qui n'écrivent
pas l'Éternel,
ceux qui n'écrivent
pas Jésus Christ,
ils ne sont pas fidèles,
ils ne sont pas constants
dans leur fidélité,
dans leur loyauté.
Ce n'est pas
la force
de ma foi
en soi-même,
c'est la taille
de mon Dieu
et ma crance
envers Dieu.
Ceux qui sont
fidèles
comme David
devant Goliath,
ou Daniel
devant toutes les
mérace que la paix
ou Moïse,
ce n'est pas
la force
de leur foi,
c'est la taille
de leur Dieu.
Et donc,
ceux qui ne craignent
pas les hommes,
ce sont ceux
qui craignent
beaucoup plus
Dieu le même.
Vous comprenez ?
Et donc,
cette fidélité
est une question
d'allégeance
à Dieu
et cette constance,
cette fiabilité
sera perçue
car nous savons
à nouveau
que cette personne
a rencontré
véritablement Dieu
et la grande Dieu
et s'est accrochée
à Christ
comme Seigneur,
nous pouvons être
sûrs qu'elle
fera tous ses efforts
tous les longs de sa vie
pour vivre une vie
constante
à la volonté
de Dieu.
Donc,
moi,
je peux attendre
qu'un chrétien,
lorsqu'il sera
exhorté,
qu'il se corrige,
qu'il se redresse.
et je peux attendre
qu'un chrétien
soit fidèle
et constant
dans les services
qu'il sera en train
de rendre à Christ
et qu'il sera fidèle
à toutes ses relations
selon les révélations
publiques
de la volonté
révélée de Dieu.
C'est d'être fidèle
à l'Évangile,
c'est d'être fidèle
à Christ,
à Christ comme Seigneur,
c'est d'être fidèle
à la parole de Dieu,
à la doctrine,
c'est d'être
tout simplement fidèle
dans toutes les airs.
Et pour plus
que je donne des exemples
dans des airs différents,
il est tout simplement fidèle
dans toutes ces airs
car il est tout simplement
fidèle
en tant que vertu radicale.
Fidélité
en foi
des convictions,
des persuasions
de nous convaincre
que nous sommes des ventes
en fruits de l'Esprit.
C'est un constat.
Et donc la foi
a pour origine
cette confiance en Dieu,
ça s'exprime
à la fidélité
à Dieu
et à sa parole
et elle devient fiable,
elle peut nous persuader,
elle peut confirmer
qu'ils nous sommes des ventes
en vrai chrétien,
en vrai fruit d'Esprit
car cette personne
elle est constante
dans sa fidélité.
Ensuite,
nous voyons la douceur
et la relation
entre la douceur
et la fidélité
elle est intéressante.
Quelque part,
la fidélité,
elle semble nous pousser
à une obéissance constante
à Dieu
fondée
sur cette conviction
des dieux
comme seigneurs.
C'est en sens
des dévoires plutôt.
des dévoires
qui est une vertu
interne.
En sens des dévoires,
en sens d'allégeance,
de loyauté,
je dois agir comme ça,
je ferai des efforts
à ne pas agir autrement,
je ne vais pas céder
à la chair
car je suis résolu,
j'ai grand Dieu
et je vais faire
sa volonté
par obligation.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et la douceur,
c'est les compléments
qu'on pourrait considérer
comme un peu plus organique
dans cette affaire.
Car la fidélité à Dieu
n'est pas tout simplement
une question
d'obligation,
c'est toujours
une question d'obligation
car Dieu est toujours
les juges suprêmes,
les créateurs.
Et Christ est notre Seigneur.
Sauf que
la manière
dont on a été
conquis par Dieu,
attiré par Dieu
afin d'embrasser Christ,
elle n'est jamais
vide d'affection,
d'amour.
L'amour des dieux
ou l'amour du Christ
nous constreint.
Et la douceur,
elle a notamment
cette signification
dans la Bible.
c'est d'avoir été
emparé par l'attirance
du Christ
qui est notre
détermination suprême,
c'est de manifester
notre amour à Christ
et nous avons été
domestiqués
comme les animaux,
c'est la racine du mot,
pour soumettre
notre volonté,
les appels
de nos passions,
de nos désirs
à la volonté
de Dieu.
Et la douceur,
elle a cet aspect
plus volontaire.
C'est une soumission
volontaire.
Donc la douceur
n'est pas
un attribut
au moins non plus.
C'est pas tout simplement
de la politesse,
de la civilité.
C'est pas non plus
la notion
d'un animal
qui a un tempérament
plus calme.
C'est pas non plus
la conception
d'être fragile.
Non,
cette personne
elle est très douce,
elle est très fragile,
elle est très faible,
introvertie.
c'est pas ceux
devant qui on peut
avoir l'impression
qu'il s'agit
des masques
et manœuvres.
Ou ceux qui veulent
éviter tout problème
et sont très pacifistes.
ce n'est pas non plus
ceux qui sont
les plus terrifiés
devant les hommes.
On est devant
des personnes
qui ont conscience
de leur puissance,
de leur droit,
de leur influence,
mais qui
contrôleront
les élans
de faire usage
de ces choses
d'une manière
non-chrétienne
afin de
transformer
parfois
une juste indignation
en manifestation
des douceurs.
C'est exactement
la même chose
qu'on voit par exemple
un Christ
qui parfois
a dû manifester
cette juste indignation
contre les parisants
avec les coups de fouet
au temps
mais qui en même temps
dans la plupart des cas
était en train
de converger
sa juste indignation
en douceur.
Lui qui aurait pu
réclamer les anges
pour les protéger
lorsqu'il pierre
et tentait
à couper
l'oreille
de ses gardes
et Christique
aurait pu appeler
des myriades d'anges.
C'est Dieu lui-même
mais au lieu
d'agir
avec agressivité
en réaction
et conscience
à toute puissance
afin de manifester
sa douceur.
Donc c'est pas
quelque chose
qui soit
tout simplement
de la fragilité
ce n'est pas non plus
la dissimulation
dramatique
ou victimiste
les stratégies
manipulatrices
d'avoir toujours
une apparence
très douce
afin
d'attendre
quels sont les objectifs
utilitaires.
c'est une bonne stratégie
pour la vie
d'être doux
car plus tôt
ou plus tard
les personnes
seront favorables
envers nous.
Et donc il y a
des personnes
qui sont très
intentionnelles
pour se porter
de manière douce
mais pas
en train de manifester
en vertu
de soi-même
mais ils sont
encore laissés
motivés
par des raisons
utilitaires
pour justifier
leur péché
ou pour
attendre
ce qu'ils veulent.
Ce n'est pas
non plus
les manques
des vitalités
des passions
des ferveurs
ou d'ardiesse.
Un prédicateur
peut être doux
tout en prêchant
avec assurance.
Christ
il s'est décrit
comme celui
qui est doux
et humble
des cœurs.
Et nous voyons
la manière
dont il proclame
la vérité
avec beaucoup
d'autorité.
Et donc il y a
sûr que certaines
prédications
dans nos jours
sont très agressives
condamatoires
ce n'est pas
ma proclamation
d'une bonne nouvelle
et ça ce n'est pas
la vraie ardiesse
biblique
la vraie passion
mais ce n'est pas
d'être doux
non plus
d'être toujours
en train d'aller
gérer les messages
d'enlever
tous les aspects
scandaleux
confrontatifs
car ce n'est pas
de la même
si nous n'avons
jamais
la perception
de la puissance
de l'évangile
de la crainte
qui devrait
s'emparer
de l'interrocteur
les personnes
n'auront
jamais
l'arrière-plan
pour comprendre
ce qu'est la vraie
douceur
la vraie douceur
c'est lorsqu'on sait
que les seigneurs
Jésus
viendra un jour
pour juger
les vivants
et les morts
et dans sa première venue
il est venu
comme en vrai vie
vous comprenez
la hache
elle est déjà mise
à la racine
de la hache
ce n'était pas ça
la prédication
de Jean-Baptiste
ce n'était pas ça
la prédication
de Christ lui-même
et donc
la douceur
doit être comprise
sur l'arrière-plan
de cette assurance
et qu'au plus
qu'on soit tenté
de dire
l'assurance des soirs
c'est presque
une assurance des soirs
sauf qu'elle n'est pas
basée sur nous-mêmes
c'est une assurance
que nous avons
des personnalités
des convictions
d'être des agents
très privilégiés
dans ce monde
ambassadeurs du Christ
les chrétiens
ne peuvent pas
souffrir
de cette conception
des manques
d'assurance des soirs
mondaines
victimisation exagérée
avoir besoin
d'un développement
personnel gospel
et chercher
à s'affirmer
sur la vanité
de ses propres vertus
tout simplement
mais si nous sommes
greffés en Christ
nous sommes héritiers
du royaume des dieux
nous pouvons être
doux et humbles
malgré notre statut
si glorieux
qui n'est pas fondé
sur nous-mêmes
mais qui a fondé
en Christ
et c'est un peu triste
que des fois
on voit beaucoup
de personnes
qui veulent donner
cette bonne excuse
pour manifester
sa colère
sa juste indignation
mais qui dans la plupart
du cas
ne veulent pas
manifester
et se comparer
comme Christ
dans toutes les autres
manifestations des douceurs
qui sont
infiniment plus
prédominantes
dans le Nouveau Testament
et donc nous sommes
devant
la description
biblique
de la douceur
qui est
à nouveau
quand on va
vers les béatitudes
des Matthieu
nous voyons
de manière
très claire
qui est
celle de
le résultat
de l'humiliation
portée par
l'Évangile
en ce qui
Christ va décrire
lui-même
les caractères
chrétiens
il commence
par les
pauvres
en esprit
heureux sont
les pauvres
en esprit
qui sont ces personnes
qui ne sont pas
en train
d'avoir
beaucoup de confiance
dans leur performance
religieuse
c'est l'opposé
des pharisiens
qui étaient très
religieux
mais très
hypocrites
et donc Jésus
il commence
en disant
heureux
les pauvres
en esprit
qui sont
les pauvres
en esprit
ça n'a rien
à voir
avec la pauvreté
matérielle
c'est la prise
des consciences
de notre
état
des pécheurs
c'est de
contempler
qui nous sommes
avec l'égard
pur des gens
envers nous-mêmes
dans notre
condition de pécheur
c'est l'opposé
du développement
personnel
c'est de
nous voir
par la
perspective
des dieux
et ça
ne peut qu'avoir
lieu
véritablement
c'est ça
qui provoque
ce qu'on appelle
la répentance
qui mène à la vie
la vraie répentance
elle ne peut qu'avoir
lieu car c'est un don
des dieux
selon la Bible
dans la vie
et dans l'expérience
de ceux qui ont été
visités par dieux
ceux à qui
l'évangile
a été présenté
et qui
dans cette expérience
de conversion
ont expérimenté
ces ministères
de saint-esprit
qui est
déjà
il n'y a pas
qu'à appeler
les ministères
des projections
des lumières
c'est d'abord
de faire
une projection
des lumières
envers dieux
dans sa gloire
et dans sa position
souprême d'autorité
c'est de ne plus
regarder envers dieux
avec nos propres
conceptions
de ce qu'on aimerait
que dieux soit
mais une expérience
réelle
de l'encontre
avec dieux
et on voit dieux
dans l'éclat
et la beauté
de sa gloire
il devient
l'objet
le plus désirable
de l'âme humaine
et en même temps
qu'il devient
l'objet le plus désirable
il devient aussi
l'objet le plus pur
la sainteté absolue
les juges parfaits
et une fois
que le saint-esprit
a projeté
la lumière
envers dieux
il projette
la lumière
envers nous
et nous
nous regardons
pas selon
notre verre
des moralités
en nous comparant
avec le rythme
ou avec les circonstances
qu'on a controversées
on se compare
à dieux lui-même
à l'image
de dieux
on se compare
à la manière
dont Christ a vécu
si nous nous comparons
entre nous-mêmes
nous pouvons
nous sentir
plus ou moins
mériteurs
de paradis
mais si nous nous comparons
avec Dieu
et avec Christ
dans leur pureté
absolue
aucun être humain
n'aurait l'audace
de se suggérer
à soi-même
qu'il ne serait
pas mériteur
l'enfer
et donc
cette contemplation
des dieux
provoque
à n'importe
quel être humain
la conviction
de la plus profonde
misère
je suis
totalement
peau
je suis
misérable
et il développe
envers soi-même
non seulement
une conscience
de cette transgression
et les mérites
de cette coupabilité
qu'on porte
mais il rénovait
envers soi-même
un sentiment
de dégoût
quel est le résultat
bienheureux
ceux qui
sont peuples en esprit
et ensuite
bienheureux
ceux qui
pleurent
les chrétiens
est quelqu'un
qui sera toujours
en train de pleurer
à cause de sa condition
pécheunesse
car ce n'est pas
quelque chose
qui se passe
tout simplement
au début de la foi
mais c'est une conscience
constante
car les restes
de la chair
sont encore là
et il est en train
de pleurer
non seulement
pour sa condition
avant la conversion
remarquez bien
l'équilibre
heureux
c'est à dire
cette sensation
des joies
absolues
et suprêmes
qui ne supprime
pas dans l'expérience
des vies
la conscience
de cette tristesse
qui nous a comprimé
pour toujours
jusqu'à la gloire
et c'est de pleurer
envers nos péchés
pourquoi nous sommes
fiers
fidèles
car ayant été marqué
par l'expérience
des conversions
à chaque fois
que les péchés
manifestent à nouveau
dans nos vies
nous pleurons
et nous réagissons
aux péchés
en développant
la soif
et la justice
volonté d'être saint
volonté de voir Dieu
dans sa pureté
et c'est qui est Christ
qui peut pouvoir
ces choses
mais juste après
la considération
des pleurés
à cause de nos péchés
la vraie importance
la vie dit
bienheureux
les doux
en esprit
quelle est la récompense
ils éritéront
la terre
quelle est la motivation
la plus opposée
à la douceur
dans la vraie vie
dans la vie
corrompue
du monde
c'est les désirs
d'avoir plus
d'avoir ce qu'on pense
être à nous
par droit
c'est le désir
de conquérir
la terre
c'est le désir
de se faire respecter
de protéger
sa réputation
et voilà pourquoi
on est constamment
hors du cadre
de la douceur
car il y a
une carence
en vide
en sens
des justices propres
des mérites
qui ne va pas
avec ce qui
nous sommes
véritablement
devant Dieu
et le monde
appartient à Dieu
et il a promis
que l'héritage
de la terre
ne sera pas
donné à ceux
qui pensent
qu'ils peuvent
la conquérir
par leurs efforts
la terre
sera donnée
au doux
en esprit
donc c'est quoi
cette douceur
c'est d'avoir
été humilié
par la conversion
l'engagement
de la religion
ceux qui ont déjà
souffert
la chute
n'ont plus peur
de souffrir
la chute
de tomber
pourquoi ?
car il n'y a
aucune chose
que quelqu'un
puisse dire
à propos de moi
qui soit pire
que ce que
Dieu a déjà révélé
au moment de la conversion
par rapport à mon potentiel
d'être encore pire
les paroles
peuvent être offensives
mais comme Dieu
a tout réglé pour moi
je ne peux plus
me laisser offenser
même car leurs paroles
même si ce n'est pas vrai
dans l'objectif
des choses dans ma vie
elles sont vraies
par rapport
à mon potentiel
pêcheur
ce sont ces personnes
qui n'ont plus rien
à défendre
plus rien
à promouvoir
par rapport
à sa propre éputation
c'est fini
l'auto-promotion
et nous vivons plus
pour nous-mêmes
nous vivons
pour la leur vie
voilà la douceur
selon l'explication
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
dans ces contextes
d'attitude
ça a à voir
avec cette notion
d'un animal
qui a été domestiqué
attrivoisé
maîtrisé
qui a encore
ses forces
et ses forces
sont maîtrisées
nous voyons aussi
que cette douceur
assure donc
ses goûts
elle a un élément
des cœurs
enseignables
la douceur
a plusieurs reprises
dans la Bible
dans plusieurs passages
elle nous parle
que nous devons
montrer
notre sagesse
par la douceur
la sagesse
d'un eau
selon Jacques
est premièrement pure
ensuite pacifique
modérée
conciliante
pleine de miséricorde
et de bons fruits
exempte
de duplicité
d'hypocrisie
les fruits
de la justice
est sémée
selon la paix
par ceux
qui cherchent
la paix
donc ni
toutes les
méthodes
d'évangélisation
ou des corrections
des problèmes
sont justifiables
nous devons
être cohérents
entre les temps
et les moyens
si mon objectif
chez les Galaxes
c'est d'amener
ce peuple
à la maturité
pour plus faire
qu'il faut l'a été
dans plusieurs moments
dans les passages
il est le modèle
des douceurs
et modérations
dans son exhortation
ce qu'il est en train
de dire ici
c'est
soyez quelque part
cohérents
à la douceur
avec laquelle
Dieu vous a traités
et si vous considérez
plus mature
spirituellement
avant tout
vous devez vous porter
comme Christ
et si vous voulez
conduire cette église
à la maturité
spirituelle
faites-les
par la douceur
c'est par la paix
qu'on va promouvoir
la paix
et donc
la dynamique
chez nous
c'est
j'essaie de reconnaître
quelle était
mon idée
à propos de Dieu
j'essaie de reconnaître
combien d'erreurs
doctrinaires
que j'avais
dans les débuts
de mon parcours
je sais que
ces premiers
grands changements
la métanoïa
la conversion
les changements
des pensées
a eu lieu
par une confrontation
des dieux
lui-même
avec
ma manière
de créer
une vision
des mondes
qui voulait
plutôt s'entraîner
des dieux
donc c'était
violent
la transformation
c'était humiliant
et même
devant mes amis
ma famille
parfois
j'ai dû être
très humble
pour assumer
publiquement
que j'avais
changé
tellement d'avis
à propos
de tellement
de choses
mais si ça a été
vrai
au fur et à mesure
dans mon progrès
spirituel
dans ma connaissance
théologique
il n'y a aucune
chose qui soit plus
opposée
à l'authenticité
de la dossure
biblique
que de ne pas
avoir
un cœur
enseignable
et car
notre progrès
spirituel
a eu un cœur
enseignable
qui a été
confronté
à plusieurs reprises
qui a dû
abandonner
à plusieurs reprises
des convictions
prégresses
je ne peux pas
imposer
envers les autres
de manière
instantanée
les changements
qui ont dû
avoir lieu
dans mon cœur
de manière
parfois
très patiente
et très douce
je dois être
ferme
je dois continuer
pour leur bien
et par amour
à les conduire
dans la bonne direction
mais je ne peux pas
forcer les choses
voilà la manière
dont Paul
est en train
de parler
des 7 messieurs
et donc
c'est cette
humiliation
de l'évangile
bon j'aurais aimé
conclure
aujourd'hui
avec
la considération
de la tempérance
ou la maîtrise
de soi
mais le temps
ne va pas
nous permettre
nous allons conclure
le dimanche prochain
une chose
à rétenir
pour conclure
c'est que
non seulement
nous devons comprendre
uniquement
ces virtudes
la vie
et la fidélité
avec cet équilibre
tu t'es
emparé par
l'amour
du Christ
et j'essaierai
d'où
et j'ai
des voix
d'être fidèle
en toute chose
mais je dois
me rappeler
que
tous ces éléments
ont été
enracinés en tout
et donc à chaque fois
la manière
la plus efficace
de rénover
ces virtudes
c'est de rester
connecté
à la racine
et donc l'exercice
qu'on peut faire
cette semaine
c'est de venir
vers les pages
des évangiles
et même vers
quelques passages
des haïts
des psaumes
pour voir
de quelle manière
Dieu
qui est tout puissant
juste
qui aurait pu
nous traiter
avec justice
et nous punir
à cause
de notre conviction
et de nos péchés
il a été fidèle
envers ses promesses
des pardon
et envers la promesse
du Christ
qui viendrait nous sauver
et donc c'est
de contempler
combien Dieu
a été fidèle
envers nous
malgré
nos provocations
contraires
à la fidélité
de sa grâce
car même s'il déciderait
de nous punir
totalement
il serait juste
et fidèle
à soi-même
mais il est fidèle
envers son peuple
sur la base
des promesses
des grâces
des pardons
et c'est sur la base
de cette même fidélité
des dieux
qu'on doit agir
dans la fidélité
envers les autres
et c'est aussi
dans la considération
suprême
de la fidélité
du Christ
qui a été
dans tout tenté
et qui a choisi
de se soumettre
volontairement
à notre face
à l'obéissance
jusqu'à la mort
des croix
c'est ce Christ
qui nous est présenté
comme l'être
les plus doux
c'est lui
qui avait la capacité
de supprimer
et d'effacer
la race humaine
de l'existence
en envoyant tous
à l'enfer
mais à cause
de sa douceur
il a dévié
l'osage
de sa juste
colère
et puissance
contre nous
à soi-même
à la croix
et il a supporté
comme ses brébis
afin de manifester
cette manière
dont Dieu
prend les brébis
égarés
en Esaïe 40
les porte sur son bras
contre sa poitrine
afin de nous traiter
de manière douce
nous ne pouvons pas
agir différemment
si nous avons été
l'objet
de cette fidélité
des dieux
de cette douceur
si nous pouvons
contempler en Christ
les oui
et amen
des dieux
pour toutes les promesses
divines
nous devons aussi
manifester la constance
de ces fruits
qui nous sont
dans la vie
les non-chrétiens
et les chrétiens
doivent attendre
d'autres chrétiens
ou des autres chrétiens
la fiabilité
pour être traités
avec fidélité
et pour être traités
avec douceur